[Musik]
zu einem neuen video leute ich bin
neugierig andré und macht man läuft hier
hatte die wenig habe schon dinge
versprechen gemacht wurden ich hatte ein
süßlicher hält video gemacht und heute
packmittel weisen ein wo genau die
werden die beiden direkt vor mir
süßigkeiten sind es schmeckt mir die
augen
[Musik]
außerdem ihr kriegt genau gleichzeitig
auch und 22
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schwimmen walken der kamera oder gar
kein fall für die nächsten jahre
wichtigkeit hier tropisch eigenen
schrank kann man sagen das liegt einfach
gratulieren
21.12
die ausbleibenden sportlichen coup aus
damit steht mehr machte genug gemacht
wird zweifach die ausgleichung
[Musik]
natürlichkeit eine durchaus erkannt dass
ich gar nicht so schlecht der architekt
ist und keine kriege jetzt immer davon
[Musik]
liga im kader für die partie gremium
dabei aber stets produktbeschreibung auf
den kleinen gummiball sich auf eine
verteidigung leicht vergrößert mit
korrigieren aber story durchaus gebiss
sind dann das nächste ding gut zwei
jahren hat die arbeit mit behinderten
oder geschwindigkeit einfach da muss man
natürlich gesamten zusammen zu erwarten
die ackermann machte zwar auch mit
achtung kinder muss auf ihr kommen
[Applaus]
wieder schlüpft ihr verein glaubt
anfangen will youtube gezeigt werden
angegriffen
wir sind kärnten sechs verleger aber
[Musik]
aber wir kennen alle die regel weg gibt
der nächste punkt natürlich 20 gleich
einmal irgendwie mein spiel sich auch
die nächste wichtigkeit ist das hier
vorkommt
das wird aber diese niederlage um bürger
mit dem klo leute damit endet dieses
video aber eine sache muss noch
ansprechen und zwar geht es um das
letzte video das möchte ich gerne ein
paar worte sagen aber ich möchte darüber
jetzt kein eigenes video machen weil
wenn ich jetzt ein eigenes video macht
bateman wird deswegen von ende von
diesem video mainz werden kannst du das
letzte video it medien und paar von euch
haben kritisiert dass ich hart video
bisschen oberflächlich ist und dass ich
mich ja eigentlich versenkung gut ist
darum bemühen ortes vor welche sein dass
dieses video mich nicht so wirklich als
gutes vorbild darf den leben weitermacht
die zuschauer so das bild entstanden ist
das alte mädchen so unbedingt sein muss
wieder sportlich sein muss unbedingt was
ich was für körpermerkmale haben muss
und dafür wurde ich erst einmal
klarstellen dafür ein dem moment einfach
meine persönliche meinung man in solchen
videos einfach ein bisschen stumpf man
in wirklichkeit erst einmal einfach
lustig sein wenn man gehörte heißt
deswegen begründet man nicht alles so
gut für mich alles weitaus mehr zum
echten leben machen würde um mehr zeit
als einfach neben der unterhaltung und
wegen meistern kann ich die kritik
durchaus verstehen deswegen jetzt hier
nochmal die anmerkung von meiner
persönlichen meinung und in keiner art
und weise müssen mädchen irgendwie so
sein
von wegen wie wird das eben beschrieben
als ca
die diakonie doppelfolge von mappus
[Musik]